oh ouais a ver chat casa por la colonia -
attendez une vidéo vidéo 3 j'en ai dit plus -
ses succès du programme happy hour de Luis
jr.  balançoire Sebastian c'est juste un livre
un vu beaucoup partiel tu veux
dire le retirer voyons ensemble
l'avatar d'Alabama Oh impertinent mwah n'est
pas Sansa oui cendre ton participant Oh
Leon présence sur cascade déjà télé de
pav transgénique tu devrais le mettre
soigneusement le jeu maori jouant désolé
ne salue pas les gens en haut en toi à
Jim excuse bonjour mr.  Le déménageur Modi dit qu'il
fera coucou merveilleux Commodores hé
merci pour la nourriture qui était vraiment bonne
ouais ne touchez pas mes muscles comme ça
vous savez que je travaille très dur
c'est impressionnant
[Rires]
je veux faire de la lune Oh miam viens avec
l'argent de ton papa Midori  ok Sébastien
si je suis là-haut bonjour nous je suis français une
fille flamande écoute écoute dis
c'est un dollar pour mon chateau du
fromage c'était un gros mec j'ai eu froid mais
j'ai pas dit que c'était pas moi oh merde
[Musique  ]
pressez ce que vous regardez rien
rien mais j'attends juste alors Oh
Oh Peter fait un nouveau HP pour dire ça je l'
ai fait hé j'ai une question si nous nous rendons tous
comment pouvons-nous avoir le couteau mais
je ne suis pas un  meurtrier
eh bien un apparaît à Helion sur l'étagère
excusez-moi j'étais le meurtre alors j'ai pris un
couteau et ils m'ont donné des coups de pied mais vous savez que je
n'ai tué personne
j'étais un gentil et doux meurtre d'un
pêcheur non il y a un crabe d'accord
Rose  cette fois ce n'est pas moi je promets que
ce n'est pas moi j'étais le dernier [ __ ] hey les gars
vous k  maintenant ce que j'étais sur le meurtre et il s'est
moqué de moi ce n'était pas moi tu peux
aller juste une fois avec moi s'il te plait laisse moi
Richter venir avec moi s'il te plait
donc je ne suis pas le [ __ ] de beurre arrête de
me tuer maintenant je suis fatigué  de ça c'est lui
squeezy es-tu ta merde
où est cette fois je vais tuer tout le monde tout le
monde  e je l'ai tellement violée avec un couteau
serrant ce que tu fous et baise
cette vie je vais dans un autre monde
au revoir squeezy
comment puis-je ouvrir cette [ __ ] de porte
ton bébé je dois sortir c'est très
étrange parce que comment ils bougent laisse moi
touche-le
laisse-moi toucher ton bébé je veux juste
vérifier s'il est vivant laisse-le toucher
va être extrêmement prudent d'accord ouais
ouais ouais je vais juste très soigneusement
très soigneusement je suis médecin je suis médecin
tu es médecin ouais  ouais
il est vivant il est vivant il n'est plus vivant
tais-toi c'était une blague je ne sais pas  Je pense que tu
as la licence de médecin oh ouais tu sais que
tu me testes
c'est moi si tu veux une fois j'ai
sorti le bébé alors il était très
beau mort mais très beau peut-être
qu'on peut essayer avec ton bébé ici tu
sais quoi faire  t aller sur la table et nous
allons faire en sorte que le bébé sorte tout de suite
mais je veux savoir si c'est un homme ou une
femme tu sais alors fais-le bien de l'
autre côté peux-tu juste être de l'autre
côté fais-le alors nous prenons  le bébé
ne bouge pas ne bouge pas
sommes-nous juste je veux juste voir si c'est un
bébé humain ou un chat ou un chien vous savez
parfois des choses étranges se produisent vous venez de
faire une échographie
faire quoi en échographie oh d'accord d'accord
je me réjouis ou  quelque chose que je ferais laisse-
moi trouver mon nous trouvons ma mère est-ce que
tu vas bien est-ce que tu
me fuis oh tu nous as trouvés non je trouve ton
ordinateur
oh ouais ouais ouais hé ne regarde pas son
bikini oh ok ouais ouais ouais  d'accord d'accord
attends devrais-je lui faire confiance
non pas de confiance je veux juste le mieux pour
le bébé
tu sais Isabel je w  ish j'ai déjà eu d'
accord, je vais mourir alors arrêtez ouais je fais
TG excusez-moi monsieur peut-être que vous avez dans mon corps
situé aujourd'hui trop ba il s'assoit au
sommet de l'Europe pour tavon
je resterais monsieur jamais je n'ai  jamais
être ivre même être ivre œdème être ivre
ivre désolé je suis très en colère contre l'anglais
désolé
je ne me suis jamais préparé pour celui-ci
toucher ma mère génial oh ouais tout le
temps
oh ne gifle jamais le copain de ta mère jamais je ne
t'ai giflé au visage
arrête de gifler ta mère rapidement, c'est
très mauvais, j'aurais déjà mangé du caca savoureux
[ __ ] ça dit que tu es une
fête mystérieuse bizarre lors de ma visite perle Omega
ce voyage vous amènera à être sur la
machine de Sicile cette cosse de pâtes copie le capitaine
mec  ok bonjour peu importe asseyez-vous et clubs
Edson ils le font - monsieur non quelques blessés
je dis que la façon dont les gens vivent très vite
giv vous savez un Josh ne connaîtrait pas les
sens séquestrés vraiment snivellus
contre laissez-moi essayer
[Musique]
merci
excusez-moi, puis-je avoir une boisson gratuite s'il vous plaît,
non, vous vous faites baiser  d'accord frère au revoir oh
qui fait comme différent juste en face
jusqu'au faux excusez-moi ouais comment puis-je en
conduire un tu vas dans ce véhicule ou
quelqu'un d'autre fait bon sang oui va dans ma
fille tu as juste besoin de démarrer le moteur
tu es très  bien mais je ne trouve pas le
bouton de démarrage pour entrer dans la voiture
mais je veux dire regarde-moi je veux dire la fille
que puis-je faire maintenant juste monter dans la
voiture
[Musique]
hé écoutez désolé les gars je vais  vomir [ __ ] de
merde tu m'as fait j'ai vu ce que tu as
fait c'était un piège
je ne peux pas te voir qu'est-ce que tu fais je
viens de tordre ton mamelon
oh [ __ ] de merde laisse mes mamelons tranquilles par
cinq oui merci de rien au
revoir bon moment  vraiment cool
parce que je suis une vidéo de taille de police avec empattement, tout
comme Elvis l'a approuvée, elle a dit ouais la
bosse comme une momie mais arrêtez l'italien
au-dessus d'un juge droney ouais même MO qui est
venu ici - âne - DeRozan sur la lune
n'est-ce pas  tailleur ça va être une chorale
où est ta motivation Oh dd-cher peut
avoir enlevé un âne tu viens ici
aujourd'hui est  aussi accrocheur lors d'une visite sainte le
11 juin oh chéri sternum un cochon toujours
pas un juif sous contrôle - ouais
dit Oh non ah nous leur disons que ça ne pousse pas
une vidéo à bouger
[Musique]